- Welcome back, everybody.
This is the final panel of
our conference The Gendered
Politics of New Nationalisms.
And I'm just going
to briefly introduce
our moderator for this panel.
And we're very
lucky to have him.
David Gergen is a public service
professor of public leadership
and also serves as Faculty
Director of the Center
for Public Leadership at
Harvard's Kennedy School.
These are positions he has
held for over a decade.
He also serves as a senior
political analyst for CNN
and works actively with a rising
generation of new leaders here
and around the world.
In the past, he has served
as White House Advisor
to four US presidents
of both parties.
And he wrote about
those experiences
in his New York Times best
seller, Eyewitness to Power,
the Essence of Leadership
Nixon to Clinton.
We're honored and thrilled
to have him with us today.
And so let me turn it over
the panel to David Gergen.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
And thank you.
And thank you for the privilege
of coming to participate.
It really to listen to
our four distinguished
speakers I want
to acknowledge up
front I've been unable
to come to the earlier
parts of this conference.
So if I repeat something
that's been said earlier,
please excuse.
You had your first session on
rights and responsibilities,
a very important
question, in part,
expanding rights in this
country for various people.
Whenever there's
been a major conflict
in this country about expanding
suffrage, or expanding
the citizenship, usually, the
expansion forces have won.
We need to keep
remembering that at a time
when so many are glooming
about what our prospects are.
You then had a session
on walls and borders.
I'm sure that Donald Trump
was trying to listen in
and to change the conversation.
But it was an opportunity to
talk about who is in and who
was out, who belongs
and who doesn't.
And this growing pushback
against immigration,
against refugees,
against migrants,
and the troubles they're
facing, which I think
is an extraordinarily
important subject
on the world stage that
deserves much more urgency.
Than it has received.
The average time for a migrant
to go home or a refugee
to go home is 14 years.
And people are
living in tent cities
in which not only
are their children
are being born, but
their grandchildren.
You know, so this issue is
very much front and center
around the world.
You've just finished
up with a speaker who
told a very important story.
And then finally, we
come to this issue--
building on the populism
theme of the last speaker,
the keynote speaker--
about nationalism.
And what is seen by
many now is a growing
clash between the
rise of nationalism
and the effort to empower women
and to ensure greater gender
equality.
In country after
country, those issues
are coming smash up
against each other.
So we have four
distinguished panelists.
And I'm very pleased to
introduce upfront Joan
Williams, who is a
distinguished professor of law
at the Hastings School.
And she's founding
director of the Center
for WorkLife Law at the UC
Hastings College of Law.
She's helped create the
field of work family studies
and modern workplace
flexibility and policies.
Joan wrote a piece in the
Harvard Business Review
that was entitled, What
So Many People Don't
Get About the US Working Class.
What So Many People Don't Get
About the US Working Class.
That article has been
highly influential.
It is the most read piece in the
history of the Harvard Business
Review.
I asked her if she was going
to give us a synopsis as part
of her presentation,
and she said,
I'm going to give an
incendiary synopsis.
Joan, over to you.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- For Trump, everything is a
masculinity contest as when he
treated that his nuclear
button was much bigger and more
powerful than Kim Jong Un's.
Are we talking about buttons?
I don't think so.
Trump's truculence reflects
what social psychologists
call precarious masculinity,
the sense that manhood is not
a biological inevitability,
but something that
has to be earned over, and over,
and over again, and that it's
a zero sum game.
So one man's is
the biggest around.
In the US, this
anxious masculinity
proved reassuring, particularly
in the face of the, quote,
witch as the alt-right
referred to Hillary Clinton.
The witch, of course,
is the deadly stereotype
that justified the murder
of over 10,000 women
in early modern Europe, many
of them targeted because they
were widows with property.
And so were seen of subversive
as then of the natural gender
hierarchy.
But the interesting
issue is not Trump,
it's the otherwise sensible
people who voted for him.
We voted with our
middle finger, said one
Trump, South Carolina voter.
Trump's election
represented a collapse
of the Democratic Party among
the white working class,
especially men.
And that's why four
crucial Rust Belt
states swung the 2016 election.
We've all heard a
lot about the divide
between the 1% and the
99%, but the divide
that's driving
American politics today
is a divide between the
professional managerial elite,
the top 17%, and
middle class Americans,
often called the
white working class.
They're really the middle 53%.
What are they so angry about?
Well, really, two things.
This slide shows the first.
It's the demise of
the American dream.
Virtually all Americans
born in the 1940s
did better than their parents.
But today, it's less than half.
And class has been etched
into American geography, which
explains that ocean of red in
rural and Rust Belt America.
Here's the 2016 election map.
And you see the Democrats have
really become a regional party.
The second reason why the
white working class is angry
is cultural.
They feel disrespected.
And for a very simple reason.
They are.
After 1970s, elites
stopped connecting
with Americans whom
prior generations gave
a place of honor.
So here is the Coit Tower
murals painted in the 1930s.
And you see how they celebrate
the nobility of blue collar
work.
That was on the wane by 1970s
when Blue collar Archie Bunker,
of All in the Family,
was depicted as racist,
and sexist, stupid, and fat.
Then came Homer
Simpson in the 1990s
who was amiable, but
also stupid and fat.
And bringing it up
to the present day,
think of Pennsatucky in
Orange is the New Black, who
was depicted as a white,
working class woman,
and we were invited to
laugh at her bad teeth.
I enjoyed all three of
these shows, actually,
but this kind of thing
has played into the hands
of the far right.
The alt-right also traffics
in precarious masculinity.
They attack traditional
conservatives
as, quote, cucks, men who
raised the children of men
who have cuckolded them.
Traditional conservatives
respond in kind,
insulting the
alt-right as, quote,
childless single men
who masturbate to anime.
The alt-right is
not blue collar.
Richard Spencer describes
the classic member
of his movement as someone
who, quote, is 30 years old,
who is a tech professional,
who is an atheist,
and who lives on
one of the coasts.
Greg Johnson, another
alt-right leader
commented the alt-right
is drawing a higher
caliber of people than
earlier iterations
of American white nationalism
because the career
prospects of college educated
whites have declined.
And a growing number
of young whites
are returning home to live
with their parents, remaining
unemployed or underemployed
for a long time.
And their resentment grows.
Again, the theme, whether
white collar or blue collar,
there's nothing quite
so dangerous as a man
without a future.
We see this when suicide becomes
a career track for terrorists.
We see it in the rise of
neo-nazis and anti-semites
at home.
The alt-right is openly racist.
Their goal is a White ethnostate
without people of color,
whether they were
born here or not.
The question is how we can
peel of the economic anger
from the racism.
I suggest three steps.
And I realize here that I have
completely screwed this up.
OK.
Going back.
I have all the pages.
They're just in the wrong order.
- Story of our lives.
- There you go.
There you go.
Let me see if I can--
well, I'll just improvise.
You'll bear with me.
One of the things that I
think we have to focus on--
well, I'm just going to read it.
You'll do the math.
I suggest three steps.
One is to provide a middle
class standard of living instead
of our economy, in which we
have rich jobs for an ever
decreasing portion
of the high elite
and muck jobs for everyone else.
The second is we need to
stop insulting people.
We need to respect
people in blue collar
jobs for simple reasons.
They're human beings.
We are committed
to social equality.
And they do important work.
When you turn on the tap in the
morning to brush your teeth,
they're the reason water comes
out, not some Harvard grad.
The third and most painful, we
need to reassess our attitudes
towards immigration.
Today, progressives typically
use an empathetic human rights
lens for immigrants and
a judgmental neo-liberal,
the race goes to the
swift, and you're not it,
lens for the white
working class.
And this is part of
a deeper dynamic.
Today, elites in both
Europe and the United States
display their cosmopolitanism
as a class act,
a way of enacting
elite class status.
We're cosmopolitan because
we went to college, where
we formed global networks.
And our job markets are global.
That's just not true
of middle class people.
It's not true of any non-elites.
Their networks are very local.
They're very rooted.
They're much more focused than
we are on community rather than
just individual achievement.
And you know, everyone tends
to stress the high status
social categories
they belong to.
That's why we cherish
our classiness
by displaying cosmopolitanism.
Middle class Americans,
on the other hand,
are very proud of
being Americans.
After all, that's one of the
only high status categories
they belong to.
To them, talk of open borders
shows a shocking and hurtful
lack of social solidarity.
And that's true of the
women as well as of the men.
Many people are shocked that
white working class women
went so heavily for Trump.
White women without
college degrees
voted for Trump by
a 38 point margin.
If they had just split 50/50,
Clinton would have won.
I wasn't surprised they didn't
vote for Clinton, although I
voted for her and worked
endlessly for her.
First, she failed to connect
with them because of her focus
on the glass ceiling.
When you think about
it, the glass ceiling
is the metaphor that
stands for my right
to have as good a job
as my elite father.
Why do they care?
They don't.
Meanwhile, she was handed
on a silver platter
sexual harassment through
the Access Hollywood tapes.
That is an equal opportunity
gender disadvantage.
She completely ignored it.
So the reason that it is is
that, even if Clinton wasn't so
class clueless, she
was running uphill
because women in
blue collar families
suffer the same dignitary
affronts as same class men.
They have the same pride
in being Americans.
They have the same
sense of violation
when that pride is written
off as mere racism.
Not to say that it's not
mixed often with racism,
but that's a different
issue from whether it
is only mere racism.
And blue collar women feel the
same loss of blue collar jobs.
And they feel it as
acutely as their men.
Because the level of sex
segregation is sharply
decreased for the likes of us.
It's sharply decreased
among professionals.
But it's decreased very little
in the working class contexts.
And so they work
pink collar jobs.
Have you ever tried to raise
a family on a pink collar job?
Not easy.
And that's what these women
in blue collar families say.
Quote, I voted for
my boyfriend's job,
said one Michigan Trump voter.
The assumption that women would
vote for Clinton to help her
break the glass ceiling,
a supreme example
of class cluelessness.
I don't know all the answers,
but I know one thing for sure.
We do need to end
class cluelessness.
It doesn't help immigrants.
It doesn't help the
people of color.
It doesn't help women
or the environment.
The only thing it
helps is the far right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Joan.
And I hope we can find
your book easily here.
Would you keep in
mind a question
I'd like to ask after
everyone has spoken
and that is, the place
of our universities
and solving this issue,
higher education is
under assault in this country.
The trust levels in higher
education have been plunging.
And it is because of a
sense of elitism that
is seen by the working class.
And I'd just like
to ask you when
we get back to the
questions about what
we can do about that?
How do we overcome and rebuild
trust with the working class
among our universities?
So now our next speaker
is Jan Willem Duyvendak--
I hope I didn't
butcher that too much--
who is a distinguished
research professor of sociology
at the University of Amsterdam.
And since January 1,
I believe is correct,
has been the director of
the Netherlands Institute
for Advanced Study in the
Humanities and Social Science
at the Royal Netherlands
Academy of Arts and Sciences.
His main fields of research,
currently, are belonging--
that's what we've
been talking about--
urban sociology, quote,
feeling at home, and nativism.
Thank you for joining us.
[APPLAUSE]
- Good afternoon.
Thanks so much, the
organizers of this conference,
for inviting me.
I really feel honored to be part
of this fantastic conference.
As a scholar, indeed,
of questions regarding
belonging, feeling at home,
nativism, nationalism,
populism, I love the
conference theme for sure.
And I fully agree that
citizenship is about more
than just formal citizenship.
But I'm not sure
whether the deep emotion
of feeling at home, the
deep emotion of belonging
should be part of our
understanding of citizenship.
Don't get me wrong, it's
important for all of us
to feel at home somewhere.
But feeling at home, belonging,
is a very particular emotion.
When you really, truly
feel somewhere at home,
it often is an
exclusionary emotion.
It's with some people
at some places.
And that makes the emotion
as a political emotion very
difficult. So the
question I will answer
is, should citizenship be based
on those we feel at home with?
And that is a difficult
question to answer.
My hesitation or my
skepticism about such
a more cultural or emotional
definition, sentimental
definition, of
citizenship is born out
of my study of my own country,
the Netherlands, which
I normally would
never speak about.
It is an interesting, small,
tiny, not very important
country.
But for today, it is important.
And I will explain
why it is important.
Because in this very
particular country,
politicians-- nor
to public opinion--
doesn't stop speaking the
language of feeling at home.
And particularly-- the white
people tell us all the time--
that they don't
feel at home anymore
in the country they live in.
And this new nationalism
that's developed
is quite puzzling, because
this new nationalism is so much
based on the idea that we
have to share all our values,
norms, and feelings.
And to be honest, those
feelings, those norms
and values, are rather
sympathetic to me
because they are progressive.
As I will try to show in
the coming 12 minutes,
there might be progress, but
they are, at the same time,
highly exclusionary
towards those
we assume do not hear in those
same values and feelings.
So let me try to explain that.
I'm not going to bother you
with a long history of this very
tiny country.
Although, there are some
historical connections
between the Netherlands and US.
There are many
misunderstandings out there.
Very briefly, some
scholars think
that the Dutch have pursued
multicultural policies.
That's not true at all.
What it's important
to realize is
that we indeed
have some laws that
stand for more than 100 years.
They're never very
divided religiously.
And how to live together
in a harmonious way
while being so different.
And therefore, we had a societal
system called pillarization.
And everybody was locked
up in his own pillar.
So Protestant pillar,
Roman Catholic pillar--
and everybody had to
live in those pillars.
And there were no connections,
no right to marry somebody
from the other pillar.
And for a long time, that
worked, really, very well.
But you have to understand
that this pillarization was
experienced over time,
more and more suffocating.
You were locked up
in your own pillar.
And you could not even
communicate with others.
And what's important
to understand
is that the 1960s
were celebrated
in this very conservative,
pillarized country--
the Netherlands-- as an enormous
liberation because people
could break out of their
pillars and come into contact
with those of other pillars.
And there are very
few countries--
Michele Lamont told
me, perhaps it's
the same is true for Quebec.
But there are very few
countries, I think,
that saw such an enormous change
as it did during the late 1960s
to early 1970s.
Almost 50% of the
Dutch lost their faith
in a period of five years.
Imagine what that
does to the country.
That's enormous.
So that became a highly
secularized country,
celebrating sexual freedom,
and it materialized, also,
in all kinds of folk as if
laws, as you might know,
regarding euthanasia,
abortion, drug policies, and--
somewhat later-- gay marriage,
but the first in the world.
So May '68 have far
more impact in Amsterdam
than it had in Paris, to
give a very short summary.
And and that's interesting,
because the Netherlands,
being one of the most
conservative countries
in Europe for a very long
time, became one of the most
progressive countries.
And that is now even more
true than in the 1970s because
over the past decades,
also, populist parties,
Christian Democrats,
and right wing liberals
came to share into those liberal
and progressive consensus,
which is obviously, very
different from the situation
in the United States, and
in many other countries, UK,
France, and so on.
So what happened was that we
were very divided in the 1960s.
And now we have become
very consensual and not
hyper diverse.
And for a while, this
developing consensus
still respected differences.
Some differences, some
tolerance was there.
There was some,
let's say, tolerant
multiculturalism
towards newcomers, often
guest workers,
Muslim guest workers,
but also some tolerance towards
the orthodox Protestants
who still live in the
Netherlands who are
a rather small group now today.
But today, particularly
the Muslim migrants
are not framed anymore,
are not tolerated anymore,
they are framed as intolerants.
And we don't have to be tolerant
towards those who are not
tolerant towards us, right?
So this is the intolerance
towards intolerance.
In this self-image of the
Dutch, in this national story,
gender and sexuality
play a pivotal role.
The parliament in
the Netherlands
doesn't stop talking
about sex and gender.
It's all the time there.
Whatever kind of debate
we have, it always
boils down to topics of
sexuality and gender.
It's interesting.
I don't have time
to go into that.
In some of the Western countries
where we see parallels,
it's more in the self-image
about gender equality.
For instance,
Denmark and France.
In the Netherlands,
it's more about
sexuality and homosexuality.
We can think why exactly
those differences are there.
But it is important to realize
that nowadays, gender equality
and LGBT rights are considered
as the core of Dutchness,
also by the far right populist.
Vilda-- you might have heard
about him-- of the Freedom
Party, he doesn't stop
talking about how proud he
is that we have gay
marriage, and also
the Christian
Democratic Parties.
We can discuss more about
why the values of the 1960s
have become so important
in the Netherlands.
But for sure, in
the past 15 years,
the embrace of those
values by the populists,
and by the far right, and
by the liberal right wing,
American Christian Democrats,
has developed an opposition
to Muslims.
That has been the core reasoning
and the logic is very simple.
The enemy of my
enemy is my friend.
And then there was
the idea that Muslims
can never care for
gender equality
or can never be LGBTI friendly.
Other scholars, [INAUDIBLE],,
John Scott, [INAUDIBLE],,
have labeled this
development, as you
might know, as homo-nationalism
or female nationalism.
Progressive forms
of nationalism that
put the women's movement
and the LGBT movement,
but also queer Muslims and
feminist movements in a very
difficult position,
because the moment
you mobilize for
those values, it
looks as if you are
immediately anti-Muslim,
and the other way around.
So the problem is--
it is fantastic, at
least in my perspective--
that progressive values
are broadly embraced,
but at whose expense?
I think we should
think about that.
And what does it produce?
It produces a self image
as if the Dutch have always
been that progressive.
So now, the story is that
since the 17th century,
the Dutch always embraced LGBT
rights and women's rights.
And it is totally essentialized.
It actually doesn't do much
justice to the history,
as I already
explained to you, we
were one of the most
conservative countries
in Europe.
And Muslims then are also
fixed in their identities.
They're eternally backwards.
They are unchangeable
and unchanging.
It means the rise of nativism.
It means that some
people are considered
to be more truly Dutch
because they embrace
LGBT rights and women's rights.
And those are then
the white Dutch.
They consider themselves
as being the true Dutch
because they are so progressive.
And that brings me
to my last slide.
So I'm quite fine
on time, I guess.
And it's somewhat linking
to the second panel
we had this morning.
Why would it be an
important story?
I almost apologetically said,
we shouldn't talk too much
about Netherlands.
But it's not just
about the Netherlands.
There is a broader story here.
And let me draw
four conclusions,
give four reasons why this
is an important story.
First of all, it's part
of a broader tendency
in which the most progressive
countries in Europe
become the most
migrant unfriendly.
You might have heard how harsh
the Danish people, Denmark,
for example, has become.
Another country, like
all the Nordic countries
that are always
outstandingly progressive,
have become very harsh and
don't want to accept migrants
so easily anymore.
Second, why is it
an important story?
Because among the
Populist Party,
things are happening that you
might, perhaps, not expect.
Even though Trump also
sometimes mentions LGBTI rights
and women's rights--
obviously, for highly
opportunistic reasons--
but we have to understand
why populist parties are
embracing that discourse.
And we see it happening.
It started in Denmark.
Then the Netherlands,
Germany, France.
So almost all Western European
countries, these very strong
populist parties, are more in
this discourse in which they
claim modernity,
in which they claim
that the Judeo-Christian
tradition is about equality
for gender and sexual equality.
It is, obviously,
then in the dynamic
of bashing Muslims in the
logic I already explained.
The third reason why
this is important,
because it marginalizes
and isolates
Muslims or religious
minorities at large
in Western European countries.
They are depicted as totally
alien and as if they can never
become truly Dutch.
And fourth, this is
important because this
translates and is part of
a world right polarization.
A world right
polarization [INAUDIBLE]
spiraled from two sites,
briefly sketched, very sketchy.
So the northwestern part
of the world and east south
part of the world, those
are opposing its order.
And / most of the
Western countries,
then, are posing as modern,
and as LGBTI friendly,
and of course, in favor
of women's rights.
But they don't frame it
in terms of human rights,
universal human rights.
No, those are Western
failures, right?
And the other side, Eastern
Europe, Russia, the Vatican,
Muslim majority countries,
they say, yes, you're right,
those are your values.
We are proudly disagreeing.
We are conservative.
We are traditionals.
We value family values
in the way we do it.
And indeed, let's stop
discussing in terms
of universal human rights.
So both sides are
reinforcing the idea
that we have only
very localized values
and that its roots
should remain like that.
And therefore, the changes
in those countries,
so well-discussed this morning,
are so difficult. To conclude,
what perhaps looks hopeful and
perhaps innocent progressive
dominance--
I can imagine you
are dreaming of it--
has a dark side.
It has a dark side.
And we have to realize that.
It has a dark side
in combination
with certain forms
of nationalism.
Because gender and
sexuality are not defined--
equal rights for
women, for LGBTI--
anymore in terms of the
universal human rights.
But only those
parts are supported
because that's part of
being Dutch, or being
German, or being Danish.
When citizenship becomes
dependent on feeling at home
with just those who are
exactly as progressive,
how inclusive are we, then?
I mean, that's the
question we ask ourselves
in the Netherlands.
If you only want to live with
the people who are exactly
the same as we are, and
then it is not important
if it's progressive or
conservative, its the idea,
what is our notion
of citizenship?
And if you put
belonging central,
that is not necessarily
then very inclusive.
Aren't we losing our ability
to deal with differences
in, for instance, my country?
And is progress nationalism,
then, perhaps not
very counter-productive?
Thanks for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you, Jen Willem.
That was a head
twisting presentation.
I think that it challenges
the conventional wisdom
that most of the authoritarian
strong man and the countries
that have been moving
to authoritarianism
have been led there by
more conservative forces
in the society not by people
who support women's empowerment,
or gay rights, or the rest.
So maybe we can explore that a
little more and the questions
to help us understand that.
It was a fascinating set of
insights and propositions.
I'd like, if we could, go deeper
on how it all works together
and how it fits.
And perhaps our next
speaker can also shed light
on that, Fatma Muge Gocek.
She's a professor of
sociology and women's studies
at the University of Michigan.
Her research focuses on
the comparative analysis
of history, politics, and gender
in the first and third worlds.
She critically
analyzes the impact
of processes such as
development, nationalism,
religious movements,
and collective violence
on minorities.
She does come to us from
the University of Michigan,
but it's also notable that
she is from Turkey originally
and is very familiar with
what's going on in that country.
And I think it fits very
nicely to compare and contrast
what we just heard
from Jen Willem.
But Fatma, thank you for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you very much for
inviting me here and enabling
me to share my views with you.
Actually, I think it is
interesting when I heard
the title of the conference--
it said Who Belongs--
the first thought I had
was, where's my passport?
And I said, well, I have
my driver's license.
That ought to be enough.
I'm saying that because I
think what I will have to say
relates to the two speakers
before because I've
spent half my life in Turkey
and the other half in the United
States.
So at this point, I
would say that mine
is more of an in-betweeness,
between the two contexts.
And all the sort of
talks up until now
has sort of triggered
in me and made
me realize that, yes, of
course, because of the subject
matter that I specialize
in, I do know social change
with all of these
social movements
pretty well because
I work on it.
But I also have some opinions
about the United States
because I have lived here.
And I am also an
American citizen.
So the reason I'm
bringing that up is,
I do not think that we have--
who belongs has this assumption
beneath that youth can only
belong to one place
and not another.
What about people who belong--
or who think they belong--
to more than one place.
That, I think, is the problem.
I mean, I have this notion
I'm working on called
ontological nationalism.
Ontology meaning social reality.
I think what's very significant
about nationalism is that you
either have one social reality
or you have another one,
but you cannot have
both at the same time.
Why am I saying that?
When I first came
to this country,
I was very miserable
not because of--
I mean, I came in
incredible conditions
to do a PhD at an Ivy
League school and all
that-- but what was important
was I thought about Turkey
and I was so sad about how
many resources there were
and how much of it
was being squandered.
It was so sad they
didn't exist in Turkey.
So when I went back to Turkey,
I would be miserable there
and say, oh my god, there are
all these brilliant people
here.
And you know, there
are no resources.
And then I realized
after a while
of living in both societies--
which I've done
now half and half--
I don't belong to
any either one.
I mean, I no longer
am considered Turkish
even though I'm ethnically
Turkish for generations.
Because in this day of
ethnic nationalism in Turkey,
that ought to be something.
But I lost that's when I started
working on the Armenian issue.
And I looked and
wrote a book on why
the Armenian Genocide and
the collective violence
against the Armenians has
been denied by Turkish state
and society for 220 years.
As a consequence of which,
everybody was sure that I was
of Armenian origin because they
cannot imagine that I could be
an ethnic Turk, which tells
you about this ontological
nationalism that
I'm talking about.
And then of course, I came here.
And when I was
here, as I said, I
live here, I have had a
lot of experience here,
I have actually lived
here more than I
have in Turkey at this
point, but I am still seen
as Turkish to a certain degree.
And this, I think,
is what we ought
to think about when we
think about, what is it?
We have to look at the
assumptions of whiteness,
not only in terms of exclusion,
but in terms of inclusion,
or resisting that inclusion.
Because obviously, I speak
English with an accent.
So I would they would
say to me, oh, you know,
wonderful, I'm
great, and all that.
And they say,
where are you from?
I'm now in Ann Arbor.
I would say New Jersey because
I came to Princeton, right?
I mean, but it's a test.
So then they would say,
where are you really from?
So I would say yes
because I'm not going to--
I mean, I refuse to have
them pigeon hole me.
It's actually very
interesting about the person,
the author who was talking,
she refused to be pigeonholed.
But I think that's
something that
comes from those of us who have
lived in more than one context.
That is, I think, the vision
of the future that will get us
beyond multiculturalism.
But in order to get, basically,
insight into how that would
work, I don't only
look at Turkey,
I also look at
the United States.
Who do you think inspires me in
the United States, you may ask.
I would say WEB Dubois is my
amazing hero at the moment
because only he
captures what I feel
through his notion of
double consciousness.
I mean, of course,
I will never presume
to have the violent past
that African-Americans
have had in this country.
That's not what I meant.
But I mean in terms of
belonging and not belonging.
And that, of course, makes
me think at the same time
that, how is it that we can
go beyond this ontological
nationalism that
leaves people out,
that doesn't leave
spaces for people?
I mean, that is the
polarization that's leading us.
At least the other view, they
enabled you to still continue
living in that society.
When you have
ontological nationalism,
they want you to disappear.
They want to send you back.
They don't allow that
space for you even here.
Where does that come from?
I mean, I will talk in more
detail about what is in Turkey.
But because I have
lived in both societies,
I always ask the same
questions of both societies
because I don't think
it is fair for me
to be only critical
in one or the other.
I have to be able to ask
the same questions in both.
And of course, I
am very informed,
let's say, by critical race
theory and feminist theory.
As a consequence, the insights
I have in analyzing and teaching
my students here-- most of
whom, of course, are Americans--
belong to and necessitate that
I know about American history.
But by specialization
on the Middle East,
also, it necessitates
that I know there.
And of course, my
own experiences
in the first half
of my life enabled
me to also know that context.
If you look into
the United States,
I think we have to have a
total reinterpretation of what
it is to belong into
the United States.
And I would do that
on two grounds.
One is, of course, the
grounds of intersectionality,
that first was developed
by Patricia Hill Collins'
matrix of domination.
And then, developed by King
Berkeley [INAUDIBLE] notion
of, you get public visibility,
in that case, for black women,
because they are excluded
from the civil rights
movement for being
women and from the
for the feminist
movement for being black.
I mean, the argument there
is you have to look at it
not only one category
in a society,
you have to look
at the intersection
of multiple categories
to see the inequality
in power relations
that are hidden there.
So that is one insight.
And if you do that, I think, as
we saw with the working class,
you see the variation.
I like the fact that you
said white working class,
because I think that has
very different dynamics
than the non-white working class
and the issues faced by them.
So that is the intersection.
And the second
thing, I think, is
history and the foundational
violences in our society
that haven't been
adequately addressed.
In our context in the United
States, if you think about--
and I will do this in Turkey,
but I'm starting by doing it
in the United States--
what are the foundational social
actors of the United States?
Who have made the
United States possible?
Our foundation
within this country
is settled on white settlers.
Yes, we say, we the
people, but who are we?
And who is included in
the we and who isn't?
I would argue that there
are three social actors.
That are the white settlers.
There are the Native
Americans whose lands
we have built everything on.
And there are the
African-Americans
who provided the labor
for all that to happen.
Look at our
ontological nationalism
in the United States.
We only acknowledge one group.
We do not acknowledge the other.
Not only do we not
acknowledge it,
they are the ones
who are suffering
the most in the United States.
And I'm not talking about
the other non-whites who
have come later
in various forms,
I'm just saying foundational.
So that is the framework I want
you to think about when I now
turn to Turkey and
explain to you what
happens in that context
because that's obviously
what I specialize in.
If you look at Turkey and
the nationalism in Turkey,
we do have Tayyip
Erdogan, the president,
and we do have, of
course, Trump here.
In my life, the two
people intersect
in a very interesting way.
Because of the work I have
done in Turkey with respect
to the Armenian Genocide
followed by the fact that I are
now working on the Kurds
because I focus on minorities,
and as a consequence, the
state violence, and others,
and I signed a petition-- along
with [INAUDIBLE] who is was
my friend in crime,
a fellow terrorist--
saying Kurds should
not be killed,
you should talk to them
instead, the president Erdogan,
said that we were terrorists.
He said there is no difference
between a terrorist machine
gun and a scholar's pen.
So as a consequence, since then,
I cannot go back to Turkey.
So I have--
I mean, I have
Turkish citizenship,
but who knows for how long.
I mean, I haven't been able
to go back for three years.
So recently, after Trump's
election, my mother,
who is back in Turkey,
occasionally keeps
calling whenever I go
on international talks,
and she says, have
you gotten back?
Is it OK?
And I'm saying, yeah,
I'm an American citizen.
What do you think?
Then the truth came out.
She said, look, you
had two citizenships.
You basically now
cannot go to Turkey.
You're down to one.
So don't make too much
noise because you'll
have no other place to go.
I said, mom, don't you worry.
I'm very close to
Windsor, Canada.
I could always go there.
I mean, so that is the other--
with respect to
nationalisms in Turkey,
what we have today, I think,
is a much more violent form
of ontological
destruction in a way
because there were initially
four founding social actors
in the transition from Empire
to nation state in that context.
There were the Greeks who
were then basically scared
and about 300,000 were
forced to migrate, also
through population
exchange, to Greece.
There were the Armenians
who also claimed,
of course-- these are the
four social actors that
claimed Turkey as
their ancestral lands.
Greeks were sent to Greece.
Armenians were, of
course, destroyed
through the Armenian Genocide.
That left the Kurds and the
Turks together initially.
What happened was that,
when you look at history
and what happened
in the transition
in writing our foundation myth
until the republic was founded,
the Kurds were seen as one
of the two essential actors
of the Turkish Republic.
Once the borders
were put in place,
all mention of Kurdish
element is totally silenced.
And I think that
explains very well why
we have the violence and
the approval of violence
not only by Turkish state,
also by Turkish society
as we see in Afrin.
Because in Afrin,
not only have Turks,
the Turkish military
had gone in there
and destroyed, and massacred,
and plundered all Kurdish
people and property.
But they say they did it,
of course, with all the arms
and armaments that the United
States and Europe provided
for Turkey.
And we haven't done anything
about it in the United States.
So for me, therefore, you cannot
separate what goes on in Turkey
and the nationalism there
from what we are doing here
because if you separate it, what
disappears is responsibility.
And we have to, I
think, bring back
that more moral responsibility.
And I'll leave there
because I don't have time.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
- Fatma, thank you
very, very much.
I'm getting a little
concerned about time.
We have one more speaker.
We're going to have a
hard time for questions.
I'm afraid it's going
to be cut short.
But we'll do the best we can.
But I do want to introduce
and bring to the stage now
Rina Verma Williams,
Associate Professor
of Political Science at the
University of Cincinnati,
where she is also an affiliate
faculty member in Asian studies
and in the Department of Women's
Gender and Sexuality Studies.
Her research and
teaching interests
include comparative Indian
and South Asian politics--
I wonder how you were going
to respond to the Northwestern
versus Southeastern tension
that we heard about earlier--
comparative Indian and South
Asian politics, religion, law,
nationalism, politics of the
global south, and gender,
and identity, politics.
Do you wake up each day
wondering which one of those
you'll study?
- All together.
- OK.
Thank you for coming
to join us, Rina.
Rina.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
- Great, thank you.
So the last speaker of
the last panel of the day.
No pressure there.
We've had such a
wonderful slew of panels.
But I'm not letting
it get to me.
Thank you to
Radcliffe for putting
this terrific set of
panels, a day and a half,
really, together.
Thanks to Dean Cohen
for inviting me.
And Rebecca and your terrific
team for just making us all
run as smoothly as silk.
It is great to be
back in Cambridge,
though it's changed a
lot in the last 20 years.
I am still traumatized
about the idea
that the [INAUDIBLE]
is gone from that slot.
I'll get over it.
I'll get over it slowly.
So I wanted to start
with this phrase,
this is not the America I know.
And I wanted to start my
brief remarks with this phrase
because I feel like I've heard
it so much in the last year,
or really the last
several years.
And I feel like it captures
a great deal of the--
I have turmoil in my notes.
And I think that's maybe
not an inaccurate word,
but the turmoil that we've
been trying to consider
during this conference.
So this phrase is
fundamentally about questions
of citizenship and belonging,
but also ownership.
Who owns America?
Who gets to decide
what America is?
So notice that for me, there
are two questions embedded here,
not just who belongs
to the nation,
but who does the
nation belong to.
I think both of those are
equally important questions.
And so I've heard this
phrase, or some version of it,
from multiple places across the
political spectrum, certainly
with the election
results last year.
I've heard this phrase
for many progressives,
many of my colleagues,
students, those
who mean to disavow what
they read, the Trump election
victory and presidency
to represent.
I initially started
with the goal of,
I'm not going to
say Trump, but I
think that's both
silly and inaccurate.
So I put it right in there.
I've heard this phrase
from immigrants,
people like my
parents who came here
50 years ago to
complete their education
and build a better life for
themselves and their kids
and to send their daughter to
Harvard to get a PhD, a better
life than the one that
they thought they could
have in their native homes.
But I've also heard
it in different forms
before Trump's
election from those
who opposed Obama in
his presidency, who
opposed Hillary's candidacy,
and the Democrats in general
in certain ways.
And then lastly, I have
to add that I have not
heard this phrase from too many
of my African-American friends,
and colleagues, and family
who have been much more
likely to say,
often with a smirk,
I don't know, but it seems
pretty much like the America
we've always known.
So there's something there that
we also need to think about.
All right.
So we all know how tribal
American politics has become.
There's no need to recap
that in any amount of detail.
So I'm not going to do that.
What is striking to me though,
as a scholar of nationalism,
is that this partisan
tribalism is actually
about the very
nature and definition
of the nation itself.
It's about what
America actually is.
It's not about what's good or
bad for America, or the best
paths forward for America, or
even how to correct past policy
mistakes or anything like that.
Anything that normal political
processes can, at some level,
handle.
Instead, what's up for
debate is the very core
question of what America is.
Just a quick disclaimer, I
want to throw in at this point.
In this talk, I will use
America to mean the US.
But I also want to acknowledge,
and I understand that doing so
can serve to alight
all the other countries
of the hemisphere, though
that is not my intention.
It's a simplifying
tool for me right now.
So I study Indian politics.
And within that, I focus
on all those things
that David mentioned,
religion, gender nationalism,
I really do try to look at
how they all mush together,
as well as law, and democracy,
and political parties.
You can't really study
one without the other.
And in some ways,
it's weird not to be
talking about India today.
I'm actually focusing
on the US, which
is in certain ways kind of
freeing in some of the ways
that Jhumpa Lahiri talked about.
And what I want to
say is that when
I see what's going
on in US politics--
I mean, in the sense
that Fatima talked about,
you can't study Indian
politics, but I've been educated
and growing my whole
life in this country,
and you can't get a degree
in political science
without knowing about American
politics in an academic sense
as well as in a personal sense.
So I feel entirely comfortable
talking about US politics.
But when I see what's going
on, I sort of naturally
try to draw on what I know
about nationalism in general
to try to make sense of it.
So that's a little
bit of what I want
to try to share with you today.
And in fact, for someone
who studied nationalism
in many forms all over
the world for a few years,
if not decades, it
actually seems crystal
clear to me what's going on.
Or at least I feel
like I can make
some sense of our
current situation
in terms that I know from
studying nationalism.
And again, that's what I
want to share with you today.
So for many decades,
scholars of nationalism
have drawn a distinction
between two different types
or forms of nationalism that
I have listed here for you.
They've gone by different
names at different times.
But at root, I
think they can best
be described and understood as
ethnic and civic nationalism.
Ethnic nationalism represents
a community of descent,
D-E-S-C-E-N-T, not
descent into chaos,
but like bloodline descent--
maybe descent into
chaos, too, eventually.
The ethnic nation is rooted
in sociocultural loyalties.
The nation's
constituted on the basis
of bloodlines, whether
real, or imagined,
or believed, kin-like relations.
So an ethnic nation is like one
big family, whether it's happy
or not.
Civic nationalism,
on the other hand,
is based in political
institutional ties.
It's more about shared political
beliefs, shared ideology
rather than a shared
ethnic background.
Now, notice that in
ethnic nationalism,
you're born into a nation.
You can't choose, or change,
or abandon your nationality.
Whereas, in civic
nationalism, citizenship
is a matter of choice.
You can choose to
leave one nationality.
You can pledge
loyalty to another one
as long as you are
pledging loyalty
to the beliefs and ideas--
[AUDIENCE SNEEZE]
--that constitute that nation.
Bless you.
And obviously, then,
both the question--
I hope that doesn't mean you are
allergic to the framework I'm
putting up.
I will go into that
Q&A. So obviously
then, both the question of
who belongs to the nation
and who the nation belongs
to, both those questions
are answered very differently
in civic and ethnic nationalism.
Ethnic nationalism, you
either belong to the group,
or you don't.
You were born into
it, or you weren't.
Whereas, civic nationalism,
anyone, in theory,
could belong to the nation.
And so hopefully, at
this point, many of you
can figure out where I'm
trying to go with this.
I believe that the
US is struggling
with the question of
whether we're fundamentally
a civic or an ethnic nation.
And to be explicit,
America has long
gotten by with the veneer
or, more cynically, the myth
of being a civic nation.
And I think that we could get
away with that for so long
as the underpinning ethnic
basis of our civic nationalism
remained dominant,
even if dormant.
And we all know what that ethnic
basis is, it's Judeo-Christian.
Perhaps even more accurately,
Anglo-Saxon Protestant,
primarily of European
descent, and white,
however that's defined at
any given historical moment.
But now, we're reaching a
tipping point as the US becomes
a minority-majority nation--
or maybe it's majority-minority,
I am never clear--
that ethnic foundation
is threatened.
Certain groups of people feel
or sense that that foundation
is threatened.
And so that foundation is
trying to reassert itself.
Or those people are trying to
reassert it, the people who
feel the sense of threat.
And these groups, these
elements, I believe,
are the ones that not
only openly support
Trump, that 30%
of the population
that will never budge
from supporting him.
But also, I think very
significant numbers
of people, that
middle 30% to 40%,
who feel the vague and easiness
of not really liking Trump,
they don't like Trump,
to some extent, I think,
maybe what Joan called
the sensible voters,
but they don't really
like the other side.
They don't trust where they
think the country is headed
or where the other
side is either
trying to take the country,
or seems willing to let it go.
A couple of things to
note regarding the debate
framed in this way.
First, the US has not
just been considered
and considers itself to be
a civic nation, but really,
the ultimate example
of a civic nation.
We're supposed to be the example
to show that civic nationalism
really worked.
What we all share that
makes us Americans,
a set of beliefs,
an ideology, we
believe in democracy, individual
freedoms, et cetera, et cetera.
And then another
thing to make note
of, the ultimate example
of ethnic nationalism
has long been considered
to be Germany,
especially pre-WWII Germany.
We all know where that went.
It was not good.
So ethnic nationalism
has a good long history
of being looked at askance.
I won't really have time
to go global with this.
I think that this civic
versus ethnic nationalism
class can explain a lot of
things around the world,
including India, which I'm
happy to go into during Q&A
or follow up if you want.
My argument is always
that, in India, we
had our Trump in 2014.
Right we had him 2 and 1/2 years
before we had ours in the US.
India has definitely
brought to power
a party that rejects a secular,
civic definition of India.
It wants to resurrect an ethnic,
Hindu religious definition
of India.
So we're at Radcliffe.
And I don't want to miss the
women in nationalism part.
So I'll close with this.
Feminist scholars
of nationalism,
if not always the mainstream
scholars of nationalism,
have long argued and understood
the critical role of gender
in constructing
national identities.
They've explained
how women are seen
as those who
propagate the nation,
both literally by
producing children,
but also culturally in
passing on language and values
to the next generation.
Women attend to hearth
and home when men are away
fighting for the nation.
They're also the reason
to fight to protect
the nation, protecting
the women and children.
And women often symbolized
the nation itself,
like some of these
images I have here
with Marianna France and this
famous image of Durga in India.
But to me, in the terms
we've just talked about,
these symbols of the
nation and of nationalism
are more linked to ethnic
forms of nationalism
rather than civic.
It's more ethnic
nationalism that women
would play these kinds of roles
in propagating the nation.
And in fact, even feminist
scholars of nationalism
haven't done enough
thinking, I would
say, about the role of women and
gender in civic nationalisms.
Maybe that's another book to
write in the next few years.
I mean, in theory,
civic nationalism
should be much less
gendered, therefore,
perhaps, more egalitarian--
I'm not sure, I have
to think about it,
we can think about it together--
than ethnic nationalism.
But the idea of a retrenchment
on an ethnic form or basis
for US nationalism also
goes some way, in my view,
to explain something that
others have found puzzling.
And that is the support of white
women in particular for Trump,
and not often just the working
class white women, right?
Even the more educated
and wealthier white women.
Despite the many
egregious reasons there
have been for women--
and for anyone, in fact--
where they could have
or should have abandoned
their support of him, if one
takes the primary concern
to be the refounding, a
reasserting, or reaffirming
the ethnic basis of US
nationalism, then to me,
at least, that makes
more sense that they
would continue to
support him if that's
what they believe he's doing.
So to conclude, just a
moment to think through what
all this might mean.
The first thing I
would say is I'm not
sure I'm trying to
make an argument
about whether ethnic or civic
nationalism will sort of win
out in this battle.
I myself am kind of rooting
for civic nationalism
to win out, not least
because it's an example I
want to see succeed.
I think the
possibilities for women
are probably better
in civic nationalism.
But to me rather,
it's more about what
combination of civic
and ethnic nationalism
will be left when
this is all behind us.
It's about whether the
underlying fear is justified,
the fear that our civic
aspects are actually
built on ethnic foundations,
and that they always have been,
whether it was
acknowledged or not,
that if the ethnic foundation
shifts as the country becomes
more diverse, will
the civic structure
that we've built on it collapse?
Was civic nationalism
myth all along?
Can we ever have a
truly civic nationalism
without that
underlying ethnic base?
These, to me, are
the questions we
need to watch, and think about,
and grapple with going forward.
I'm not going to stand here and
pretend to have any answers.
But I'm certainly interested
in watching the game
and hope that the
outcome is the right one.
And no matter what,
I always believe
in trying to make sure we're
asking the right questions.
- Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Just a word, I might point
out that in the last couple
of weeks, the Parkland kids
came here from Florida.
There were seven who
came to Kennedy Schools
and on the of day and we had
a chance to talk to them,
and ask them, and try
to figure out, how could
it possibly be at
a time when there's
a lot of negativity about the
millennials, and who they are,
and what they represent,
and these kids come forward
and they're poised, they're
articulate, they're passionate,
and they understand
history, and they seem
to understand our civic life.
And it turns out they have
a very strong civics program
at that school.
And it made a difference in
terms of the civic nationalism
you were just discussing.
But I want to ask Joan, briefly.
I have just two questions.
And we're going to go to the
floor for as long as we can.
Joan, I briefly asked in
beginning, what about elitism
in American universities?
A Pew poll found that a
stunning 40% of people
think that universities
are bad for the country.
Bad for the country.
They're our crown jewels.
So what do we do?
If Larry [INAUDIBLE]
came to you and said,
I'm taking over Harvard's
[INAUDIBLE],, what should I do?
- Well, I'm going to give
a short answer because I'm
eager to hear from the audience.
I think there's been
a systematic program
for several decades to undermine
American education, starting
with the inner cities, but
certainly not ending there.
And I think it's
been very effective.
And it's been
absolutely devastating
for American civic life.
And I think the attack
on the universities
is just the latest
version of that.
- And where is that
coming from, the effort
to dismantle and discredit?
- I think that it is
coming from people
who would prefer a passive
and uneducated electorate.
As I say, I'm eager to
hear from the audience.
I'm not really sure.
- Let me ask the
group one question.
The United States
is soon going to be
a country where the
whites Caucasians are
no longer the majority.
We're going to have a
majority of minorities.
And the central issue becomes,
can a multi ethnic society
succeed?
And I just would
like to ask you,
is there an example
you can point to
of a multi-ethnic society
that has been successful?
Or what country would you point
to that's come the closest?
- Well, it depends on how you
define success, doesn't it?
- Well, it does.
- But just to say
something, I mean,
if you want to have a
post-colonial take on why is it
that universities are taken
on, one can argue that we are
switching from an entitlement
society to an achievement
society.
And then universities,
of course,
are where you go when
you achieve something.
Whereas, the rest,
of course, no longer
have the entitlement,
which they had always
thought was achievement that
came because of what they did
rather than because of where
they were born and who--
- Working class
families would argue
that the sons and
daughters who are
going to these elite
universities do feel entitled.
And they're there because
they had a certain amount
of entitlement in life.
- Their children feel that.
- Well, then others look
at it and say, well, you've
got it in, you've
got a legacy, you've
got all these things
that are going on.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Just saying, we
did have a legacy,
that's why I got into Yale.
- Yeah.
- But again, let's go
back to this question.
Can multi-ethnic societies work?
Which ones are
coming the closest?
- One thing, when
you say multi-ethnic,
you assume that all ethnicities
are equal to each other.
And they are not.
multi-ethnic means that,
because of history, because
of intersectionality,
with power,
some ethnicities are always
more privileged than other ones.
If you bring them
together, then,
you cannot assume that
they are all the same.
- Given that, how do countries
overcome the challenge, please?
- I wonder if I could ask a
question in return which is,
which society has not
been multi-ethnic?
Right the myth one can
have a majority ethnicity,
but I think anything but
a multi-ethnic society
at some level is not
a fully real thing.
- Go back to the
fundamental argument
underlying all of this, that
many people no longer feel
at home, and a lot
of those people
are coming from the
majority who now
feel like they're
turning into the minority
and are being
overwhelmed by others who
are coming in from the outside.
- In the US, there is this
kind of new theorizing
in terms of super diversity,
that all countries,
many countries, many cities
become minority majorities.
So indeed, the white mainstream
will then be disappearing.
And I agree with you.
This suggestion that it's
new, but also the suggestion
because we have so
many ethnicities,
and therefore,
there's no mainstream
anymore is not
very sociological.
I mean, there are
many ethnicities.
But indeed, there
are still rather
dominant groups and groups
that are less dominant.
And it might be that numerical
changes makes the majority even
if they are perhaps not the
majority in numbers anymore,
but they are still
the mainstream.
Nevertheless, they might
feel threatened, right?
And that's what's happening
with many white Americans
at this moment.
But there are then basic
sociological questions to ask.
Does that mean, indeed, that
the mainstream, as such,
is totally disappearing?
Is that what is happening?
I don't think that
multi-ethnicity necessarily
implies that, to be honest.
And the second question,
it's a more painful question,
why do those white people
feel so threatened?
Or to frame it
even more painful,
why do they feel entitled
to have a higher status
position than others?
And in that sense, I'm
ambivalent about what
Joan said.
On the one hand,
of course, you're
totally right that the white
working class deserves dignity
and we treat them with dignity.
But the question is whether they
will be satisfied with that.
The thing is that they
often think that they
deserve to be better off.
I mean, otherwise, how
to confront their racism,
their homophobia, and so on?
So I'm sympathetic that you want
to give them back their value,
but the thing is, is that
what they are asking for?
- I totally agree with you.
But to add to that,
whites are not also
one monolithic category either.
I mean, that is also,
I think, a problem.
We have to divide the
whites who are critical,
like most of you in this
room, including you all,
and whites who have
naturalized that privilege,
and who want to
sustain that privilege,
and have no interest
whatsoever in saying,
why do we have this privilege?
Where did it come from?
Should we have it in
the past, in the future?
Should we share it
with other people?
I mean, I want whites
to be normalized
whites and critical whites.
Critical whites are, I think,
very important because change,
positively, can only emerge
when those critical the whites
are together with
the non-whites.
Otherwise, we will stay
in totally polarized
from each other.
Why do I say this?
I am an ethnic Turk.
When I studied the
Armenian Genocide,
I belonged to the
perpetrator category.
That was important.
I did not belong to
the victim category.
I mean, who is victimized
in this situation?
We have to be aware
that those who
belong to the dominant
white category
can also own responsibility.
That's what [INAUDIBLE]
talks about,
is that they can say,
we are responsible,
this is our society.
For change, we will be
aligning with the non-whites
and change the other
normalized whites.
[APPLAUSE]
- Joan?
- Do you mind?
Do you want to--
- Go ahead.
- I think that racism
and a sense of class,
what's been called the
hidden injuries of class,
I think they've gotten
all mixed up together.
And I think some people are
not interested in giving up
their racism.
And I think for those people who
are not giving up their racism,
I'm not interested.
I'm not going there.
But I think for a lot of
people, if you say to them,
there are a couple of deals
that are being on offer.
You can continue to have
your McJobs and your racism.
Or we can offer you
the dignity that
is due to all working
people of all races
because you do important work.
And you're entitled to
a middle class standard
of living because we're
one of the richest
countries in the world.
And if you're interested in
that deal, we have a wide tent
and we welcome you here.
I think that we wouldn't get
all of the white working class.
I think we would
get enough of them.
And I think we would treat our
fellow citizens with dignity.
Let me just say one
quick other thing.
You know, are these
people racist?
They are white people.
White people are racist.
We're racist, too.
- Are you saying all
white people are racist?
- I'm talking about
40 years of studies
that show that the professional
managerial elite prides
themselves on their merit.
So 40 years of studies
shows that they fault people
of color for lack of merit.
The white working class prides
themselves on their morality.
So 40 years of studies
show that they fault people
of color for lack of morality.
I'm not in favor of
either kind of racism.
But I find it truly
troubling and off
putting when elites
use anti-racism
as an excuse for snobbery.
And I do not think that
helps people of color.
[APPLAUSE]
- I'm just curious
about your view
and how it's consistent with
treating people with dignity
if they feel you're
calling them racist.
- Well, I'm interested in
whatever Rina wants to say.
That's a good handoff.
- Rina is going to
speak about going back
to our previous conversation.
Go ahead, please.
- I'm not sure which
question I'm answering.
The one thing that
came to my mind
in terms of your
earlier question
about whether any multi-ethnic
society has ever succeeded,
it brought to mind
the word fear.
The fear of what is--
I'm not saying
you're afraid, I'm
saying the question
made me think of that.
Or maybe you are afraid.
I don't know.
But I don't want to assume.
The fear of, how is
this going to work?
How is this American
experiment in civic nationalism
going to work without
the underlying
ethnic basis or foundation
that's always been there?
And that is a scary question.
Like I said, I stood
up there, and I said,
I don't know the answer.
I hope it works.
I think it can work.
Exactly how it will
work, I'm not sure.
But that's the sense
I get underneath.
Joan, I love your deal.
I would grab it in a moment.
I'm not sure how many
takers one would get.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Is it worth it?
- Oh, it's definitely--
I think we have to try.
There's no question.
And then whether people take
it or not, that's on them.
But the studies
I've seen and heard
that I find very
perturbing, where
if you go to people
in mining jobs, oh,
what about a program to retrain?
We don't want to retrain.
We want our old lives.
We want our old jobs.
We want things to be
the way they were.
And that fear of, how is
this all going to work later?
We don't see how it can work.
And we don't see what our
place in it is going to be.
I'm not sure we like
how it's going to look.
That that's what
comes to mind when I
hear a lot of these questions.
I have no idea which
question I answered.
- Our host has very
properly suggested
that we go to the floor.
So there is at least
one microphone here.
And two of you can line.
We'll go as long as we can.
Yes, sir, please?
- My name is Robert
Chu from Cambridge.
And I have a great concern
about our fragile democracy.
I saw a movie last night
at the Kennedy School.
It's on Netflix and
available for anyone.
It's called Get Me Roger Stone.
And if that doesn't get people
fighting mad to take back
our country, it should.
As a Matter of fact, there's
another film I just saw,
The Darkest Hour, with Churchill
standing up and saying,
we're going to fight for island,
and standing up to Hitler.
And both of those provoked
to think, my question is,
if the Democratic Party--
which is not an
ideal party at all,
it has a lot of problems--
if we don't fight like hell
and take back the
Congress, and vote out
the spineless Republicans, we're
going to lose our democracy.
And I don't know if anyone
would agree with that.
We got to do it.
- Thank you.
Does anybody want
to respond to that?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
- Let us get a few.
- OK, go ahead, please.
- Hi, I'm a graduate
student from Boston College.
I have a question for maybe
the sociologists, but maybe
everyone.
There are some sociologists
in the field who
believe that we should
think of America
or theorize America as an empire
rather than a nation state.
Would you agree with this?
And if so, do you think it
changes the question about who
belongs or doesn't?
- You all want to wait to
hear all the questions?
Is that what you're saying?
- Well, I know who
the sociologist is,
Daniel [INAUDIBLE],, who
writes about US imperialism.
Of course, it's very
important to differentiate
European imperialism
from American imperialism
because we do it
through the economy,
we do not politically
go and colonize it.
We colonize through
the lifestyle,
through the consumption,
through shopping malls,
and things like that.
I mean, what does that
do to other societies?
And what happens when that
intersects with neo-liberalism
and the priorities of profit
rather than human lives
is something, yes, we
do have to think about.
But that all requires
critical self-reflexivity.
We are not, as a
nation, as American, I'm
talking about,
critically reflexive,
because I don't think we
study our history enough.
We are too much
focused on present.
Of course,
neo-liberalism'squestion
premise is that it is
universal, there is no history,
that it doesn't matter.
I think history matters.
We have to reexamine
our history.
- And much less, study the
history of any place else.
- Exactly.
- I'm not a sociologist, but
I feel qualified to jump in.
I'm familiar with the
work you're talking about.
My only concern about
that is that sets up
as if empire a nation state
are not closely interrelated.
- Oh, yes.
They are the same.
- There is no
empire that has not
had a nation state as its
foundation, say, being Indian.
The first question, just really
quick, and maybe a couple
of questions at a
time, one thing that
popped to mind very quickly
is two different things.
I mean, at one point, at
the beginning, you said,
take our country back.
And that made my ears stand up.
But then you said,
take Congress back.
So I see those as
two different things.
They're not really--
take our country back
made me immediately
want to say, didn't you
hear what I said about
whose country it is?
We have to figure out
who's country it is.
But take the Congress back,
that's a different question.
I can sign up for that.
- Please.
Hi, I'm trying to
phrase this question,
because I want to come back to
the question which I think you
all punted on a little bit,
to offer and challenge you
to offer a prescriptive norm of
what ideal multi-ethnic society
could look like.
Because if, we Rina is saying,
civic nationalism is the best
we can hope for in a
world of nation states--
that's where we are--
and if, as Jan was
saying, that even
espousing certain liberal
ideals of gender equality,
or sexual equality, or
LGBT rights itself becomes
suspect as an effort to push out
the other, the Muslim, and so
forth.
Can a multi-ethnic society
articulate and demand adherence
to certain liberal values
that are, ultimately, designed
to be liberal and protective of
the other, the LGBT, the women,
and so forth.
And the challenge I
see, the conflict I see
is that we also tie ourselves
up in knots the tolerance
everybody, of everything.
And that's where the
hate speech comes in.
That's where the values come in.
Does not have to be accepted
within a multi-ethnic society?
Can a multi-ethnic society
exist by accepting everything?
What that does is then just
become nothing and chaos.
So what is the
prescriptive ideal?
- Thank you.
Please.
- Thanks again for the question.
I think that many of us indeed
gave a rather dark picture
this afternoon.
And the terms of civic
and ethnic nationalism
are very helpful to describe it.
Because in the many
countries we are discussing
and we are
researching, there is,
I think, a shift from
the civic to the ethnic.
And that's not only
true in the US,
but it's also true in
France, which you might see,
it very specific,
but it becomes also
very much defined
and very specific
values that are, of course,
propagated as universal.
But at the same time,
as you've described
very nicely this
morning in the session,
they are highly
specific, and also
exclusionary towards others.
So this is broader tendency
from specific to ethnic.
That's all that we want.
At the same time, my [INAUDIBLE]
to the slightly more ambivalent
because it is also about
the rise and the embrace
of progressive values.
And in the earlier
days, you would
expect that being progressive
and being tolerant
would go together.
The problem is that,
also, progressive people
can be highly intolerant.
But I do see, in
the Netherlands,
it has a performative effect.
So all the time
emphasizing women's rights,
and other, and LGBT rights
creates something like--
OK, but then we should be
tolerant towards minorities,
groups in a disqualified, in
a discriminated situation.
So why then not having the
embracement of the notion
of tolerance itself?
And not just for those specific
groups, but we should rethink.
And that gets closer
to, of course,
then the civic notion
that is not relativistic.
To be totally clear, I
totally agree with you there.
But that is far from
saying, some people
are, by color, or by
birth, or whatever,
more core of the
nation than others.
Everybody can become
part of that nation.
- Does anybody have a model
nation we can look to?
- I try to avoid that.
There is not such
a country, I guess.
- You say what?
- I'm curious to hear
from the audience,
but I mean, they are clearly
hesitant to name countries that
are closer to this ideal
of civic nationalism.
What we do see is that many go
from civic to ethnic or a sense
of nationalism.
But there are good examples.
You can think of
countries that have
become more civic recently.
I'm afraid that's very
hard to come up with.
- Let me just add that ethnic,
of course, you can touch,
you know, you can see
to a certain degree.
Civic is an abstract notion.
Modernity's main problem
is that the notions,
the concepts we have, have a
certain level of abstraction.
You cannot find
them actually there.
And I'm now very upset
about this imagined part
of the imagined community
that nationalism entails.
Because when you say
imagined, everybody
imagines it differently.
So what happens if those
imaginations don't all go
along?
And how do you take that theory
and what happens in practice?
There is a lot of variation.
The only insight I have
is [INAUDIBLE] insight.
I think if we have
as individuals
the unit of analysis, it's
going to be difficult.
We have to think
of communal again.
Maybe that is the way to
go, of communal rights
and responsibilities.
- I'm eager to hear
the other questions.
But let me just say
one brief thing.
This is not the first time
we've seen this movie, folks.
I mean, my mother was Jewish.
She wasn't considered American.
I'm married to a Catholic boy.
There was a time when
the Catholics and Irish
were considered black.
We have done this our
whole national lives.
We can do it again.
We just need to want to.
And we just need--
and I would never--
I mean, I've worked in identity
politics my whole life.
I've worked on race and
gender my whole life.
We just need to add back class.
Yeah?
- I was going to
ask the question.
But now I'm just going to
make a very simple statement
about primary education.
And that's because,
basically, we're
standing here in
this room because
of what we've learned 30, 40
years ago in kindergarten.
And I am a child of a white,
American, working class
woman born abroad.
And she's still
waiting for the Trump
miracle, which is supposed
to come and fix everything.
- Bless her heart.
Yeah.
- So when I look at my
teenage children who
go to an American
school in Nigeria,
their attitudes towards LGBT
and smoking come from school.
I didn't teach it at home.
And so I'm wondering
if maybe this
is a class here for young
people, just like 20 years ago,
30 years ago in America
we were studying diversity
and what that meant.
I think, though, it has to
include the new minority, which
is working class America.
[APPLAUSE]
- Just to say, I
mean, my next project
is to write a book trying
to reinstill civics
in the United States.
- Good!
I think the hook is here.
Take it away.
- What'd you just call me?
I'm kidding.
Thank you very much
to our panelists,
to David Gergen for
moderating this panel.
We could go on for another hour.
It's a sign of the skill with
which the conversation was
conducted and the brilliance
and thoughtfulness
of our panelists.
Thank you very much.
I'm going to offer
some quick concluding
remarks and some thanks.
I realize that I'm
standing between you
and the weekend
and/or the reception.
I know that's in there, too.
Liz, thank you.
So I will be brief.
I want to thank--
this has been a
fantastic conference.
I want to thank, first, the
academic ventures group that
planned it, Becky Wasserman
and her amazing staff,
Sean O'Donnell,
Jennifer [? Birkat, ?]
Kristen Osborne, Moore Madden.
I want to thank Jessica Vickland
and our fantastic events staff.
I want to thank the
planning committee, a number
of professors who, actually, for
over a year, planned the event.
That includes Professors
Sarah [? Blige, ?] Melanie
[? Kammets, ?] Jane
Kamensky, Michelle Lemont,
and Mark Tushnet.
And I'd be remiss if I didn't
thank our dean, Liz Cohen.
I've known Liz for a long time.
[APPLAUSE]
She is a fellow scholar
of US politics, as am I.
But she insisted
throughout my time
here as Radcliffe that
we include, indeed,
prioritize global perspectives.
And she insisted
on this centrality
of the arts and humanities
to what we do, science,
as well, by the way.
And so when you see
Jhumpa Lahiri, Celeste Ng,
Cynthia Lopez, Maria Agui
Carter, and others, thank Liz.
She has really
introduced that and made
it central to our culture.
And as you may know, she is
concluding her decanal services
here within a few months.
We're not going to lose her.
I know, but yes.
But we're going to
miss you as a dean.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
I do want to offer just a
quick set of concluding remarks
because Liz told me to.
Who belongs?
This is a quotidien call.
It is answered every day,
as is the question posed,
by institutions
and rules that are
every bit of a part
of our fabric and life
but are often less visible,
sometimes entirely invisible.
So I want to focus on two
categories, written rules
and unwritten
rules, if you will.
We heard about written
rules in the world
of birthright citizenship.
We heard about how
structures of law,
particularly
birthright citizenship,
converts the state
into something
of an emperor of whim,
of chance, of just, where
did you happen to
be born, and then
converting that
into your status,
your identity, your resources.
We heard Martha Jones talk about
the limited and discretionary
ways in which birthright
citizenship was applied
and extended in her
wonderful metaphor,
birthright citizenship as the
haven and the scythe at once.
We heard Sarah Leah
Whitson describe
about how, in Jordan, Jordanian
birthright citizenship was
linked to Jordanian
fatherhood, but not
the Jordanian motherhood
or to the children
of Jordanian mothers
without Jordanian fathers.
And it's worth remembering
that the birther
movement, or that meme,
for a while, linked
to a different kind
of citizenship, one
actually not connected
to the 14th Amendment,
but connected to article
two of our constitution,
the original
Constitution, and the way
that it defines eligibility
for our presidency.
We also talked about
immigration structures.
Immigration judges
of the sort that
were talked about by Professor
Carey Huang of Boston College
Law School.
And it's interesting
that those judges
are answerable to and
employed by not the Supreme
Court, the judicial branch, but
by the executive branch, which
is one reason that they
are subject to some
of the directives of
Attorney General Sessions
and of President Trump,
which means at some level
that the access to an
independent judiciary
in our country is itself
conditioned upon citizenship.
And as another way of
thinking about written rules,
we heard about the really
interesting research of Tali
Mendelberg, and the way in
which even a voting rule, which
is to say, what's the threshold
that determines by which
something gets passed or failed
in a vote, majority, or simply
unanimity, but the
way that affects
the way people participate.
So the written rules are
there with us everywhere.
But I think rules
are often sometimes
most powerful when
they're implicit,
when they're unwritten,
and when they're assumed.
I have a friend, an
African-American man
I've known for a long
time, a good friend.
He's a PhD psychologist.
He told me something recently
that kind of stuck with me.
He said, well, when you hear
about the canary in the coal
mine, the important
point when you're
hearing about that metaphor
of the canary in the coal mine
isn't about the canary.
It's about the context.
It's about the gaseous
threats that are
emerging from the coal mine.
And so the point isn't
really about the thing that
keels over and stops chirping.
It's about the context.
And that invisible context, I
think, is with us everywhere.
To get back to, for instance,
Tali Mendelberg's idea
of just the number of people
in the room who are women.
You know, a lot of the
experimental subjects
probably didn't know that,
oh, look, it's all women,
or it's 80% women as
opposed to 20% women.
Yet, that invisible
fact structured
the way they treated
others and the way
they rated them is influential.
You can think about Fatma Muge
Gogek's point about, well,
does everybody just have one
identity, just one nationality?
That's a common assumption
that we all make.
Or Joan Williams', I think, very
thoughtful, poignant criticism,
have working class people of
whatever race in this country,
in the United States, been
stripped of a certain degree
of cultural citizenship or
of educational citizenship?
Have they been
assumed irredeemable
based on where they live?
I note as somebody who grew up
in a small town in the Midwest,
that that is not merely a
simple, white racial fact
that she's pointing to.
There were many Native
American reservations
that went from 60/40 Obama
Romney to 60/40 Trump
Clinton for some of
the same reasons,
namely, that their economies had
been wrecked in recent years.
Does that mean that
dynamics are not racial?
Of course not.
Does that mean they're
deeply involved with class
and economic trajectories?
Yes, it does.
We heard Nulifer
Gole's discussion
of Muslim women in
Europe, especially France,
and the idea of the burkini,
and her asking this question of,
does belonging entail the
subjugation of our identities
for some people?
For instance, of the idea of the
corporeal person or personhood,
and how people, especially
Muslim women, treat,
cover, and display
their own bodies?
Or think of the father in
Jhumpa Lahiri's beautiful story,
Il Confine, The
Boundary, that father
who had retreated to the
countryside, who, in a sense,
had exiled himself from his
own nation, his new nation,
living away from the
city so he didn't
have to expose his
shattered teeth,
so he didn't have to
expose his infacility
with the official tongue.
So who belongs strikes me as the
fundamental political question
of our time.
And our answers often
come in the form
of borders, not merely
concrete borders,
but categorical borders.
And those borders can be fluid.
They can be paraffine.
They can be cemented
in a Trumpian fantasy
and built very high.
But those borders are
always constructed,
even if the president
wishes to construct them.
But that means not just that the
cement borders are constructed,
but so are the categorical ones.
And so, to get back to one of
the calls from one of our very
first speakers today, professor
Kerry Kari Hong, maybe we,
in part, start changing those
borders by changing our talk,
by changing the
talk, including--
to get back to Joan Williams--
the talk that we regularly
and assumably carry
on in our universities.
And I'll conclude there.
[APPLAUSE]